ones too much together and that's
unfortunately over for young christophe
duda losing two games today against
maximum vagiela grav that match is over
three points for maximum vagiela who's
having a very good tournament now so far
and i lost them zero points for duda
magnus also about to gain all three
points i guess the bar says a hundred
yeah it's definitely a hundred here
white's pawns are just marching forward
actually we might even see a checkmate
on the board black's king is completely
helpless it's left on its own and
two pawns a king and a rook can easily
checkmate that black king black's pawn
meanwhile takes an age to start motoring
down the board and start running
so yeah no counter play here for
nakamura he knows he's lost with one
minute on the clock maybe he'll just try
and figure out a way to make it less
easy for magnus i don't see any hope
though
for nakamura
um yeah magnus in great form i like the
fact that nakamura is playing on it's uh
it's always good to at least force your
opponent to work at least force them to
show that they know how to win
but at the end magnus's pawns will trap
that black king
yes
um really not so much to do
just push the black pawn just show us
why it's going to end in checkmate i
think that's the
yeah i mean
the only the only danger there is in
this position is that uh
that white maybe traps the king and
there's some style mating issues but i
mean even that is going to be a tall ask
because
there's a pawn and a rook on the board
and 10 seconds now for nakamura will he
click that resign button or will he play
on and show us the checkmate okay he's
playing on good
no he's not okay he makes a move it
seems but he resigns at the same time
magnus takes the win after another
really nice end game wow it's a dominant
match victory for magnus carlsen winning
two
games against hikaru nakamura to